then we ask who is your biggest rival I
have no Rivals that's the right and then
we ask who is your favorite opponent to
play in terms of classical chess I would
definitely say that Karan and aronian
are the top two and in terms of faster
time controls Nakamura for sure so yeah
I think that's spot on and this one
interesting one have you reached your
Peak as a chess player I peaked a few
years ago really but the decline is not
going so fast uh for the moment yeah
2019 was was video year and then we
asked what is your single biggest
achievement if choosing only one my
single biggest achievement in chess is
uh um having the highest rating of all
time um and keeping the number one spot
for um more than 12 years r